so we have a parallelogram right over
here what I want to prove is that its
diagonals bisect each other so the first
thing that we can think about these
aren't just diagonals these are lines
that are intersecting parallel lines so
you can also view the Miss transversals
and if we focus on D B right over here
we see that it intersects DC and a B and
since they're those we know our
parallelogram we know that they're
parallel this is a parallelogram we know
that alternate interior angles must be
congruent so that angle must be equal to
that angle there and let me make a label
here let me call that middle Point E so
we know that angle a B E we know that
angle a B e must be congruent to angle
CD to angle C de by alternate interior
angles of a transversal intersecting
parallel lines and alternate interior
alternate interior angles now if we look
at if we look at diagonal AC or we
should call it transversal a so you can
make the same argument it intersects
here and here these two lines are
parallel so alternate interior angles
must be congruent so angle Dec must be
so let me write this down angle Dec must
be congruent to angle BAE BAE to angle B
angle BAE by for the exact same reason
now we have something interesting if we
look at this top triangle over here in
this bottom triangle we have one set of
corresponding angles that are congruent
we have we have a side in-between that's
going to be congruent actually let me
write that down explicitly we know we
know then we prove this to ourselves in
the previous video that parallelograms
not only are opposite sides parallel
they are also congruent so we know from
the previous video that that side is
equal to that side so let me go back to
what I was saying we have two sets of
corresponding angles that are congruent
we have a side in between that's
congruent and then we have another set
of corresponding angles that are
congruent so we know that this triangle
is congruent to that triangle by angle
side angle angle side angle so we know
that triangle I'm going to go from the
blue to the orange to the last one
triangle a B E is congruent to triangle
blue orange in the last one CDE
CDE by angle-side-angle congruency
angle-side-angle congruence now what
does that do for us well we know if two
triangles are congruent all of their
corresponding features especially all
the corresponding sides are congruent so
we know that side we know that side EC
side EC corresponds to side E a or I
could say side AE we could say side a
correspond a corresponds to side C e to
see e their corresponding sides of
congruent triangles so they're measures
or their lengths must be the same so AE
must be equal to C let me put two
slashes it's already used one slash over
here now by the same exact logic we know
that de we know that let me to focus on
this we know that be e we know that be e
must be equal to de be e must be equal
to de once again so their corresponding
sides of two congruent triangles so they
must have the same length so this is
corresponding sides of congruent
congruent triangles so be e b e is equal
to de and we've done our proof we've
shown that look diagonal DB is splitting
AC into two segments of equal length and
vice versa ac is splitting DB into two
segments of equal length so they are
bisecting each other now let's go the
other way around
let's prove to ourselves that if the if
we have two diagonals of a quadrilateral
that are bisecting each other that we
are dealing with a parallelogram so let
me see so we're going to assume that the
two diagonals are bisecting each other
so we were assuming that that is equal
to that and that that
right over there is equal to that given
that we want to prove that this is a
parallelogram and to do that we just
have to remind ourselves we just have to
remind ourselves that this angle is
going to be equal to that angle it's one
of the first things we learned because
they are vertical angles so let me write
this down
see label this point CED angle C II D is
going to be equal to or is congruent to
angle so I started C is B EA angle B e a
and that what is that well that shows us
that these two triangles are congruent
because we have a corresponding size if
it congruent an angle in between and
then another side so we now know that
the triangle keep this in yellow
triangle a a EB is congruent to triangle
a B is congruent to triangle d ee c d e
c bi side-angle-side congruence
side-angle-side congruence by SAS
congruent congruent triangles fair
enough now if we know that two triangles
are congruent we know that all of the
corresponding sides and angles are
congruent so for example we know that
angle CDE angle CDE angle C D E is going
to be congruent to angle you can see CDE
is going to be congruent to BAE BAE is
going to be congruent to angle B to
angle BAE and this is just corresponding
angles corresponding angles angles of
congruent of congruent triangles and now
we have we have this transversal or this
can't this kind of transversal of these
two lines that could be parallel if the
alternate interior angles are congruent
and we see that they are these two are
kind of candidate alternate alternate
interior angles and they are congruent
so a B must be parallel to CD
so a bee she'll just draw one arrow a
bee must be parallel to CD a bee is
parallel to CD by alternate interior
angles congruent of parallel lines I'm
just writing in some shorthand forgive
the cryptic nature of it LM saying it
out and so we can then do the exact same
log we've just shown that these two
sides are parallel we can then do the
exact same logic to show that these two
sides are parallel and I won't
necessarily write it all out but it's
the exact same proof to show that these
two so first of all we know that this
angle is congruent to that angle right
over there
and then we know actually let me write
it out so we know that angle AEC angle a
EC is congruent to angle D let me EB I
should say de be angle D e be they are
vertical angles vertical angles and that
was our reason up here as well vertical
vertical angles and then we see that
triangle AEC must be congruent to
triangle de B by side angle side so then
we have triangle AEC must be congruent
to triangle D EB by s.a.s congruence
then we know that corresponding angles
must be congruent so that we know that
angle so for example angle c AE angle c
AE must be congruent to angle BD e BD e
angle b d e and this is their
corresponding angles of congruent
triangles so c AE c AE let me do this in
a new color c AE c AE must be congruent
to be to be de b d e and now we have a
transversal the alternate interior
angles are congruent so the two lines
that the transversal is intersecting
must be parallel
so this must be parallel to that so that
we have AC AC must be parallel to BD BD
by alternate interior angles alternate
interior angles and we're done we've
just proven that if the diagonals bisect
each other if we start that as a given
then we end at a point where we say hey
the opposite sides of this quadrilateral
L or that ABCD is a parallelogram